i've
been recently talking a lot with john
donahue from brazil brazilian jiu jitsu
fame i don't know if you know yeah
that is yeah in fact i'm talking about
somebody who's good at what he does
yeah and he speaking of somebody who's
open-minded the reason
doing this ridiculous transition is for
the longest time and even still
a lot of people believed in the
jiu-jitsu world and grappling world that
leglocks are not effective in jiu-jitsu
and he was somebody
that inspired by the open-mindedness of
dean lister
famously to him said why do you only
consider half the human body
when you're trying to do the submissions
he developed an entire system on this
other
half of the human body anyway i do that
absurd transition
uh to ask you because you're uh you're
also a student in brazilian jiu jitsu
is there something you could say how
that has affected your life
what you've learned from grappling from
the martial arts
well it's actually a great transition
because i think
[Music]
one of the things that's so beautiful
about jiu jitsu is that it
it does what we wish we could do in
every other area
of life where we're talking about this
difference between
knowledge and ignorance right like like
there's there's no
room for [ __ ] right you don't get
any credit for [ __ ]
there's uh the difference but the the
amazing thing about jiu jitsu is that
the the difference between knowing
what's going on and what to do and not
knowing it is as
the gulf between those two states is as
wide as it is in
any thing in in human life
um and the it
it's spanned it can be spanned so
quickly like you
like you you didn't each increment of
knowledge can be doled out in
five minutes it's like here's the thing
that got you killed
and here's how to here's how to prevent
it from happening to you and here's how
to do it
to others and you just get this this
this
amazing cadence of discovering your
fatal ignorance
and then having it remedied with the
actual
technique um and i mean just
for people who don't know what we're
talking about it's just like this the
simple
circumstance circumstances like
someone's got you in a headlock how do
you get out of that
right someone's sitting on your chest
and you know they're in the mount
position
and you're on the bottom and you want to
get away how do you get them off you
they're sitting on you
you your intuitions about how to do this
are terrible even if you've done some
other martial art right
and once you learn how to do it
the difference is night and day it's
like you have access to a completely
different
physics but
i think our understanding of the world
can be much more like jiu-jitsu than it
tends to be
right and i think we should all
we should all have a much better sense
of
when we should tap out and when we
should recognize that our
our you know our epistemological arm
is barred and now being broken right now
the problem with
debating most other topics is that most
people
it isn't jujitsu and most people don't
tap out right they don't
even if they're wrong even if it's
obvious to you they're wrong and it's
obvious to the
intelligent audience that they're wrong
people just double down and double down
they're either lying or lying to
themselves or they're just they're
bluffing
and so you have a lot of zombies walking
around and zombie world views walking
around which have been disconfirmed
as emphatically as someone gets armbard
right or someone gets choked out in in
jiu jitsu
but because it's not jujitsu
there they can they can they can live to
fight another day right or they can
pretend
that they didn't lose that particular
argument and
uh and science when it works is a lot
like jiu jitsu i mean science
when you falsify a thesis right when you
think
you know dna is one way and it proves to
be another way
when you think it's um you know triple
stranded or whatever it's it's like
there there is a there there and you can
get to
a real consensus um so jiu-jitsu
for me it was like it was more than just
of interest for self-defense and and uh
you know the the sport of it it was just
there was something it's a language and
an argument
you're having where
um you can't fool yourself anymore
like this there's a first of all it
cancels any
role of luck in a way that most uh
most other other athletic feats don't
it's like in basketball you know you can
even if you're not good at basketball
you can take the basketball in your hand
you can you can be 75 feet away and
hurl it at the basket and you might make
it and you could convince yourself
based on that demonstration that you
have some kind of talent for basketball
right
enough you know 10 minutes on the mat
with a with a you know a real jujitsu
practitioner when you're not one
proves to you that you just there is
it's not like there's no lucky punch
there's no you're not going to get a l
you're not there's no lucky rear naked
choke you're going to perform on someone
who beyond you know who's
you know marcelo garcia or somebody it's
just it's not going to happen
and having that aspect of
of um
the usual range of uncertainty and
self-deception
and and [ __ ] just stripped away was
was really a kind of revelation it was
real it was just an amazing experience
yeah i think it's a really powerful
thing that accompanies whatever other
pursuit you have in life i'm not sure if
there's anything
like jiu jitsu where you could just
systematically go
go into a place where you're
um that's honest where your beliefs get
challenged
in a way that's conclusive yeah i
haven't found too many other mechanisms
which is why
it's uh we had this earlier question
about fame and
ego and so on i'm very much
rely on jiu jitsu my own life as a place
where i can always go to
to have my ego in check and that
that has uh effects on how i
live every other aspect of my life
actually even just doing any kind of
um for me personally physical challenges
like even running doing something that's
way too hard for me and like pushing
through
that's somehow humbling some people talk
about nature being humbling in that kind
of sense
where you kind of
see something really powerful like the
ocean
like if you go surfing and you realize
there's something much more powerful
than you that's also honest
that there's no way to uh that you're
just
like the spec that kind of puts you in
the right
uh scale of where you are in this world
and you just
does that better than anything else
we should say it's only within its frame
is it
truly the the kind of the the final
right answer to all the problems it
solves because
if you just put jiu jitsu into an mma
frame or a real a total self-defense
frame
then there's a lot to a lot of
unpleasant surprises to discover
there right like somebody who thinks all
you need is jiu jitsu to
you know win the ufc it gets punched in
the face a lot
uh you know even from uh uh even on the
ground
so it's um and then you bring weapons in
it's like when you
talk to jiu jitsu people about you know
knife defense and self-defense right
like that
that opens the door to certain kinds of
delusions but the analogy to martial
arts is is
fascinating because on the other side we
have
you know endless testimony now of fake
martial arts
that don't seem to know they're fake and
are as dilute i mean
they're impossibly delusional i mean
there's great video of joe rogan
watching some of these videos because
people send them to
them all the time but like literally
they're people they're people who
clearly believe in magic where the the
master isn't even touching the students
and they're
they're flopping over so this this
there's this kind of shared delusion
which you would think maybe is just a
performance and it's all a kind of
elaborate fraud but there are cases
where
the people and there's one you know
fairly famous case if you're a
connoisseur of this
of this madness where this older martial
artist who you saw flipping his
students endlessly by magic without
touching them
issued a challenge to the to the wide
world of martial artists
and someone showed up and just you know
punched him
in the face until it was over clearly he
believed his own
publicity at some point right and so
that like it is
it's this amazing metaphor it seems
again it should be impossible but if
that's possible
nothing we see under the guise of
religion or
or political bias or even you know
scientific
bias should be surprising to us i mean
it's so easy to see the work that that
you know cognitive bias is doing for
people when
when you can get someone who is ready to
issue a challenge to the world
you know who thinks he's got magic
powers yeah that's uh human nature on
clear display
you